what was John Cena's longest Title reign  well I've the been the champ of being  stupid for  40 years  uh let me see  if John Cena played Minecraft  well I would build worlds that's what  would happen if I played Minecraft  what did John Cena play in football well  that answered simple football it's a  sport that all players play and there's  positions I think the question should be  what position did John Cena play in  football so I'll answer this question  football  what is the Johnson potato salad joke  there is a small large group of folks  out there who think that I'm rather  Bland kind of like potato salad it's  bland it's something you sit down at a  barbecue for the sake of having another  food I guess it's  better to be called potato salad  than a steaming heap of bull  so what are you gonna do